- Thank you, Steve, for your introduction.
Your honor, distinguished
guests, ladies and gentlemen,
I heard that there were
new citizens from Iran,
Afghanistan, Egypt,
and others, and Turkey,
so I'd like, in their language, to say
(speaking in foreign language)
We're delighted you are citizens
of the Unites States now.
My fellow immigrants,
citizens, and Americans:
I previously participated
in two similar events.
The first being my own
naturalization ceremony
in Philadelphia where
our nation's independence
and Constitution came into existence.
Then, years later, I spoke
to a group of new citizens
at Monticello, in Virginia,
where the author of the
Declaration of Independence,
Thomas Jefferson, built his home.
Today, I'm honored to be in Boston,
at the John F. Kennedy Library,
Designed by I. M. Pei,
internationally known Chinese-American
architect who designed this building.
Next to this harbor that has
welcomed so many immigrants
in the nineteenth century,
including the ancestors of
the late John F. Kennedy.
President Kennedy knew
firsthand that America was both
and continues to be a
nation of immigrants.
He wrote a book on the
subject, as you heard,
entitled A Nation of Immigrants.
Later, as the President
of the United States,
he was a constant champion
of immigrants and refugees,
never forgetting that he, too,
came from a family of immigrants.
He laid the foundation for
the Immigration Act of 1965,
which placed the American
Dream within reach
of people from every nation on earth.
As was demonstrated a while ago.
I was deeply fortunate
that the United States
welcomed a multitude of
international students
to receive their education in our country.
While studying at Stanford, I met my wife.
We're married and living in London
the same year as John
F. Kennedy was elected.
I will never forget that night.
For hours, we followed
the election returns
from United States,
putting coins into a radio
to hear the latest dispatches
from Radio Luxembourg.
Because the election was so close,
we used up all of our change.
We were broke, newlyweds,
but everything felt so terribly exciting,
as if the future of the
world was up for grabs.
We were thrilled that such a
gifted young man and idealist
had been elected to the
nation's highest office,
and we celebrated the fact
that the election demonstrated
that the United States
had overcome yet another
great obstacle, transcending
a century of prejudice.
Let me explain.
In the 1850s, a powerful
political movement
swept our country,
urging politicians to
restrict immigration.
Their party was called the
party of Know-Nothings.
They particularly disliked
Catholics and the Irish.
In other words, the very ancestors
of the President whose legacy
is preserved in this library.
But, thank God, throughout our history,
we have also had great leaders, idealists,
and patriots who rejected the
idea of a constricted America,
defined by bloodiness, religion, and race.
For example in 1858, none
other than Abraham Lincoln,
our first Republican President,
argued that America's
ideals were available
to all who understood
the principle set forth
in the Declaration of Independence:
namely, that "We hold these
truths to be self-evident,
"that all men are created equal."
All men.
He reminded the newcomers to America
that they have, as Lincoln
put it, a right, and I quote,
"To claim it as though they
were blood of the blood,
"and flesh of the flesh
of the men who wrote
"the Declaration, and so they are."
End of the quite.
The founders of our nation did not claim
that they had created
a more perfect union,
but rather they had created
a framework and foundation
for a just society,
setting guiding principles
for future generations.
That's not to say that the
ideals our country set forth
were always upheld.
Because throughout our
history men and women
have fought bitterly, and
occasionally violently,
over the promise of America, its laws,
and its institutions, and
have sacrificed their lives
to preserve this county.
Like you, America did not and does not
rest on its past laurels.
It moves forward, knowing its
imperfections and limitations,
yet always working to overcome them.
Equality, justice, the supremacy of law,
a representative government
predicated on true democracy,
the respect for the intrinsic
worth of the individual
and the acknowledgment
of individual rights
embedded in the Bill of Rights.
Namely, these values must be taught,
discussed and remembered
time and time again.
We have to know our
history, now your history,
and the evolution of
our republic, our legal
and economic systems as well
as our cultural heritage.
This year also marks 150th anniversary
of the 14th amendment,
one of the most noteworthy
additions to the Constitution,
which bears a special significance
for those gathered here.
It states, and I quote,
"All persons born or
naturalized in the United States
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof,
are citizens of United States."
It is thanks to that
amendment, we are here today.
The declaration that all
men are created equal
was a revolutionary idea
in 1776 and still is.
The emergence of United States
constituted a challenge to the world,
because ours was a new nation,
founded upon the highest
ideals of the enlightenment,
believing in the potential of human beings
to build a free society in
which the rule of law prevails,
and no one is above the law.
President Kennedy understood that freedom
is not simply a right, however.
With it comes responsibility.
Today we celebrate your
citizenship, but also to ask you
to accept the solemn obligations
that citizenship brings.
Today's a rite of passage
for each one of you.
You will soon be a part of
something bigger than yourself,
namely, the United States of America.
That is what I felt when
I was about to be sworn in
as a citizen of the United States.
Like you, I was full of
joy, trepidation, and hope.
I remember tears in my eyes as I swore
that I would support and
defend the Constitution
and the laws of United States of America.
I felt as if I were getting married again,
and once more vowing my
devotion, until death us do part.
As a citizen of United States,
I have tried to live up to the challenge
JFK so famously issued
to us, and you heard it,
and to the nation in
his inaugural address:
"Ask not what your country can do for you,
"ask what you can do for your country."
So what can you,
this country's newest citizens,
do for your adopted homeland?
Challenge us, help us to do better.
As citizens of this
country we can, we must,
participate in the work of our democracy.
In the routine of our democracy.
That means undertaking a
myriad of small actions,
most of which do not take
place on election day.
Read, learn, listen to
others, help your neighbors,
speak out against injustice, and vote.
Study our nation's glorious
past as well as its trials,
tribulations, and tragedies.
By doing so, you fulfill
your rights and obligations as citizens.
Thomas Jefferson once described America as
"crusade against ignorance."
He believed that a nation
could not be both ignorant and free.
If that is true, and I believe it to be,
then we must all seek knowledge,
understanding, and tolerance.
Today, our history is a
great source of comfort
and inspiration in the
complex and conflicted world.
Studying it will help us
recognize the difference
between wisdom and ignorance,
between light at the end of tunnel
and the dangers of an oncoming train.
In my own quest for knowledge,
I still feel amazed at my good fortune.
I am first-generation American-Armenian,
born in Tabriz, Iran.
I came from a rich civilization
with 2,500 years of history and culture.
But as I journeyed from
an empire to a republic,
I began to understand the power of freedom
and the rule of law and
the protections provided
by our Constitution and Bill of Rights.
In the process, I realized
that becoming an American
did not mean discarding my culture,
my faith, and my identity.
I came to be a part of America,
not apart from America.
I was glad to be included in America.
I want to conclude with a few
words from another address
that I gave during my
naturalization ceremony.
And I said the following,
"We know America is not perfect,
"but we see it as perfectible.
"For us, America is not just
a past; it's also a future.
"It is not just an actuality,
it's always a potentiality.
"America's greatness lies in
the fact that all its citizens,
"both new and old, have
an opportunity to work
"for that potentiality,
for its unfinished agenda."
Here in this beautiful location by the sea
that President Kennedy loved,
I am reminded of a
quotation often attributed
from a contemporary of his,
Dr. Martin Luther King,
Jr.. who said, and I quote,
"We came in different ships,
"but we are all in the same boat now."
We're all in the same
boat. The boat of America.
Again, my most sincere
congratulations today.
I'm delighted and honored that
you're your country's legacy,
from United States of America.
Thank you for being
citizens, good luck to you.
We're very proud of you.
(applauding)